hello and welcome to this video playing
it will call em okay answer rather you
trading mismatch in this game let's see
what we would we get Kings Indian
probably an awesome modern young and the
modern defense like to play this
classical set up against the modern no
Knight f6 is back into a young back into
the Kings Indian yeah I know black
should probably go naija for to disturb
white a bit if he allows me that's okay
I can also go in directed to d2 if it
allows me to play 92 it's usually not
such a such brilliant idea um okay let's
see if I can use the we get 6 square
there are some tactical I dsm there is
something with takes h3 ng4 bit I have
to admit that I have forgotten how it
works
ok it's no probably I should have taken
first now we can take with the night if
you once mean okay probably okay he
wants to do it I wanted to say probably
he doesn't want to do that anyway but ok
anyway I'm quite happy with this let's
see
oh that looks dangerous fam if i take
night takes 96 is the exchange and g
takes 92 looks difficult that is six
square if you place age 6 i'll take
defaults even more more horrible and gym
so i will win the exchange but hmm yeah
okay I will go there first and then
think about it I I can also play just
let's say g3 here just g32 to open up
the the whole thing the most is 6 is
this is quite irritating here
I think I'll go g3 if he takes on g
three and a half Bishop g5 coming and so
on the Stokes excellent and here I'm
going to take yeah okay let's just grab
that pawn n95 is nice and that's the
queen is hanging otherwise it would be a
cool move okay so rookie one threatening
95 yeah let you five I had an idea
especially if Aiden reply okay it's not
not a big deal Queenie 297 checkmate sir
it's funny
I hope I'm not overlooking something
ignite 95 but I can hear okay here hmm
there's also Queen two is six which
makes quite some sense
now I'll take take the material and no
m-maybe this yeah I have to have to be a
little bit cautious in my king on the G
file is something to pay attention to
this one maybe maybe this one okay all
my time I have to look look at the clock
yeah that I'm not unhappy about that he
corrects my my paw instruction and
closes chief i'll check yeah threatening
this shouldn't be bad and when you
cannot move the bishop now so I'm really
aim time to close to blundering
currently a lot yeah Luke is hanging now
kind of shaky what I'm doing
yeah how to how to win this probably
with some some mating attack you can
play we should be five
alright
black resigns okay yeah objectively
objectively of course why he is winning
but it's def still some some work to do
then gathers a fairly normal position
night takes okay i had this was more
what i was thinking but i think g4 is
interesting yeah this is what I
remembered from when I studied this some
time ago there is some issues here with
with those captures for example after
this night takes the black position on
the King side is very very shaky he has
hard time to save gardens pieces this I
have 96 which is a problem okay you went
with this yeah I think here he has to
avoid bishop at high offices basically
giving away material as he cannot
prevent that night e 6 business now I
mean he allowed that and now of course I
can't take this but I felt that this is
also a good idea the thing I'm not wrong
taking the exchange is also fine of
course but this is very nice check now I
think I played it okay up to here maybe
somewhere somewhere around here I could
have played more some more decisive move
but it's it's a huge edge okay they're
not much as he can do can keep this
owner then maybe route which is six and
tween f3 and so on there is no real
attack or play that that black has okay
thanks for watching